[Music]
when Reverend Jim Jones founded the
Peoples Temple in 1955 few could have
imagined its horrifying end this
progressive religious movement rose in
popularity and gained support from some
of San Francisco's most prominent
politicians but in 1977 amidst
revelations of brainwashing and abuse
Jones moved with several hundred
followers to establish the commune of
Jonestown in Guyana billed as a utopian
paradise the colony was more like a
prison camp and when a congressional
delegation arrived to investigate its
conditions Jones executed his final plan
on November 18 1978 nine hundred and
nine men women and children died after
being forced to drink poisoned flavor
aid that grisly image has since been
immortalized as shorthand slang for
single-minded cult-like thinking they
drank the kool-aid today there are
thousands of cults around the world it's
important to note two things about them
first
not all cults are religious some are
political therapy based focused on
self-improvement or otherwise and on the
flip side not all new religions are what
we're referring to as cults so what
exactly defines our modern understanding
of cults and why do people join them
broadly speaking a cult is a group or
movement with a shared commitment to a
usually extreme ideology that's
typically embodied in a charismatic
leader and while few turn out as deadly
as Jonestown or Heaven's Gate which
ended in a mass suicide of 39 people in
1997 most cults share some basic
characteristics a typical cult requires
a high level of commitment from its
members and maintains a strict hierarchy
separating unsuspecting supporters and
recruits from the inner workings it
claims to provide answers to life's
biggest questions through its doctrine
alone with the required recipe for
change that shapes a new member into a
true believer and most importantly it
uses both formal and informal systems of
influence and control to keep members
obedient with little tolerance for
internal disagreement or external
scrutiny you might wonder whether some
of these descriptions might also apply
to established religions in fact the
word Cultus originally described people
who cultivated the worship of certain
gods by performing rituals and
maintaining temples but in time it came
to mean excessive devotion many
religions began as cults but integrated
into the fabric of the larger society as
they grew a modern cult by contrast
separates its members from others rather
than providing guidelines for members to
live better lives
a cult seeks to directly control them
from personal and family relationships
to financial assets and living
arrangements cults also demand obedience
to human leaders who tend to be highly
persuasive people with authoritarian and
narcissistic streaks motivated by money
sex power or all three
while a cult leader uses personal
charisma to attract initial followers
further expansion works like a pyramid
scheme with earlier members recruiting
new ones cults are skilled at knowing
whom to target often focusing on those
new to an area or who have recently
undergone some personal or professional
loss loneliness and a desire for meaning
make one susceptible to friendly people
offering community the recruitment
process can be subtle sometimes taking
months to establish a relationship in
fact more than two-thirds of cult
members are recruited by a friend family
member or co-worker whose invitations
are harder to refuse once in the cult
members are subjected to multiple forms
of indoctrination some play on our
natural inclination to mimic social
behaviors or follow orders other methods
may be more intense using techniques of
coercive persuasion involving guilt
shame and fear and in many cases members
may willingly submit out of desire to
belong and to attain the promised
rewards the cult environment discourages
critical thinking making it hard to
voice doubts when everyone around you is
modeling absolute faith the resulting
internal conflict known as cognitive
dissonance keeps you trapped as each
compromise makes it more painful to
admit you've been deceived and though
most cults don't lead members to their
death they can still be harmful by
denying basic freedoms of thought speech
and Association cults stunt their
members psychological and emotional
growth a particular problem for children
who are deprived of normal developmental
activities and milestones nevertheless
many cult members eventually find a way
out whether through their own
realizations the help of family and
friends or when the cult falls apart due
to external pressure or scandals
many cults may be hard to identify and
for some their beliefs no matter how
strange are protected under religious
freedom but when their practices involve
harassment threats illegal activities or
abuse the law can intervene believing in
something should not come at the cost of
your family and friends and if someone
tells you to sacrifice your
relationships or morality for the
greater good they're most likely
exploiting you for their own
[Music]
you